der konflikt mit nordkorea ist
hochgefährlich der diktator kim jong un
lehnt verhandlungen abrüstet munter
weiter auf und testet immer mal wieder
seien bomben arsenal- jetzt sagt
nordkorea verkündet auch eine
wasserstoffbombe zu besitzen
die wohl gefährlichste waffe überhaupt
auf dieser welt wie diese funktioniert
ob das land tatsächlich über das
entsprechende know how darüber verfügt
und wie forschungsteams weltweit
versuchen nordkoreas aufrüstung
aufzudecken
jetzt sind klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen wir haben ja schon
öfter mal über atombomben und ihre
verheerenden konsequenzen gesprochen
jetzt reden wir klartext über
nordkoreas auf rüstungsprogramm und
liefern alle wichtigen fragen und
antworten die man ja wissen muss frage
eins wie genau schon jetzt eine
wasserstoff atombomben funktionieren mit
der spaltung von atomkernen sowie
heutige kernkraftwerke eine
wasserstoffbombe funktioniert
vereinfacht gesagt genau andersherum
atome werden nicht gespalten stattdessen
verschmelzen hier bei atomkerne und das
tatsächlich setzt noch einmal deutlich
mehr energie frei als eine kernspaltung
die energiegewinnung mit kernfusion ist
deshalb viel effektiver aber übrigens
trotzdem ungefährlicher als die
kernspaltung darüber haben wir ja im
letzten video über wendelstein 7-x
berichtet die hohe energie freisetzung
führt aber bei der wasserstoffbombe zu
einer viel gefährlicheren waffe konkret
fusionieren besonders schwere
wasserstoffkerne deswegen auch der name
haar bombe den heißt ja das chemische
symbol für wasserstoff um die
verschmelzung überhaupt in gang zu
bekommen braucht es hohem druck und
unvorstellbare temperaturen von 100
millionen grad dann verschmelzen die
wasserstoffkerne zu helium ganz nach dem
vorbild der sonne
der größere helium kern ist dann
allerdings leichter als die ausgangs
kerne doch masse kann nicht einfach
verschwinden sondern wird umgewandelt in
eine riesige menge energie
die berühmt berüchtigte einstein
formel also eh gleich ma c quadrat also
energie ist gleich masse mal
lichtgeschwindigkeit zum quadrat der
lichtgeschwindigkeit ja eine konstante
ist kann man die in der formel auch
weglassen um das prinzip zu erkennen und
das heißt masse kann
in energie umgewandelt werden gleich m
und genau das passiert bei der
wasserstoffbombe und das bedeutet eine
unvorstellbare sprengkraft die us
atombombe die auf hiroshima abgeworfen
wurde hatte eine sprengkraft von 3 10
kilotonnen tnt einer wasserstoffbombe
dagegen kann eine sprengkraft von
mehreren hundert kilo tonnen entwickeln
viele sprechen deswegen bei der
wasserstoffbombe von der gefährlichsten
und mächtigsten waffen der welt
überhaupt ihn zukommt dass sie so klein
gebaut werden kann daß sie auf den kopf
einer interkontinentalrakete passen
würde eine super brisante kombination
die erste wasserstoffbombe überhaupt
wurde übrigens vor rund 65 jahren im
rahmen eines sets gezündet die
sprengkraft der amerikanischen bombe war
auf einer pazifikinsel die war 800 mal
größer als die der atome von hiroshima
und das obwohl es sich hierbei um einen
prototypen gehandelt hat in einem krieg
wurde eine wasserstoffbombe gottseidank
bisher noch nie eingesetzt frage 2 wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass nordkorea
wirklich eine wasserstoffbombe geburt
hat nokia hat ja in diesen tagen nach
einem test bekannt gegeben dass das land
nun auch über eine wasserstoffbombe
verfüge das ist bisher von keiner
unabhängigen stelle bestätigt werden
doch fest steht messinstrumente in
einigen ländern dieser welt haben
erschütterungen verzeichnet
beispielsweise das deutsche
geoforschungszentrum kurz gfz dass elf
minuten nach der zündung in nordkorea
eine erschütterung mit einer stärke
von mehr als 6 gemessen hatte die
wellenform endet expertenteams zufolge
sehr den seismischen wellen die auch bei
früheren nordkoreanischen waffen tests
gemessen worden waren
doch diesmal sei die sprengkraft der
bombe höher gewesen einige hundert kilo
tonnen tnt hätten wohl diesmal dahinter
gesteckt bislang hätten die tests er
eine detonation von maximal fünf und 20
kilotonnen tnt entsprochen so die
einschätzung des gfz doch trotzdem
lassen sie sich nicht so einfach alleine
aufgrund erschütterungen zwischen einer
wasserstoffbombe oder einer
herkömmlichen atombombe unterscheiden
er ist der nachweis von radioaktiven
stoffen in der atmosphäre wäre
tatsächlich ein eindeutiger nachweis
schon nach den nordkoreanischen
nukleartest in den jahren 2006 und 2013
in spezifische zenon isotope
nachgewiesen worden
bislang sieht es aber so aus als sei
keine radioaktive wolke unterwegs mit
hilfe von modellrechnungen könnte diese
simuliert werden um den nachweis
radioaktiver produkte zu ermöglichen
viele experten und expertinnen alpen die
zündung einer wasserstoffbombe durch
nordkorea dennoch für unrealistisch
vielmehr sei ein anderer typ vorstellbar
beispielsweise eine fusions verstärkte
atombombe also eine mischform dabei wird
einer plutonium bombe tritium
beigemischt ein radioaktives
wasserstoffgas frage 3 gegen lauten die
atomwaffentest in nordkorea ab nordkorea
hält das alles natürlich streng geheim
was man aber weiß die waffentests in
nordkorea finden unter der stadt auf
einem testgelände unter einem gebirge
in einer tiefe von etwa einem kilometer
bei einer bombenexplosion beet
natürlich der boden forschungsteams
weltweit messen mit einem ass netzwerk
von rund 170 instrumenten die
seismischen wellen die dabei entstehen
vor allem die messwerte in der nähe von
nordkorea also in china oder südkorea
beispielsweise sind besonders
aufschlussreich 2016 hatte nordkorea
bereits schon einmal verkündet eine
wasserstoffbombe gezündet zu haben
damals hatten auch russland und japan
erschütterung des bodens verzeichnet
doch die meisten atomphysiker und siegel
waren sich schon damals einig dass die
erschütterung zu gering für eine
wasserstoffbombe gewesen sein doch zu
hundertprozentiger sicherheit kann das
niemand sagen denn die wellen dem boden
verbreiten sich je nach beschaffenheit
des gesteins unterschiedlich gut und wie
das rund um die testanlagen aussieht das
wissen nur die nordkoreaner und geologen
seismologen und atmosphärenforschung
steam sind übrigens nicht die einzigen
die sich für nordkoreas auf
rüstungsprogramm interessieren auch
geheimdienste versuchen schon seit
jahren mit hilfe von satellitendaten und
luftproben mehr details zu dem
atomwaffenprogramm des landes zu
erfahren dazu werden sie auch
erschütterungen der erde aus und hören
zudem ozeane nach schallwellen ab
dennoch ist weiter unklar wie
umfangreich das waffenprogramm von kim
jong un
tatsächlich ist vierte frage wie
gefährlich ist nordkorea kurs klar ist
dass nordkorea atomwaffen besitzt unklar
ist wie leistungsstark diese sind und
wie groß die sprengköpfe sind denn das
ist ausschlaggebend um den grad der
bedrohung abzuschätzen mitte dieses
jahres hatte nordkorea aber spätestens
der ganzen welt gezeigt dass sie mit
ihrem raketenprogramm weiter sind als
vermutet damals hatten sie die
integration and rakete song 14 getestet
nordkoreanische raketen waren bis in
japanische gewässer und sogar über
japan hinaus geflogen
nach vermutung mancher experten und
expertinnen hat nordkorea wurde
mittlerweile sogar
interkontinentalraketen die in der lage
wären das amerikanische festland zu
erreichen
der bau einer wasserstoffbombe ist aber
weitaus komplexer als der eines
kernspaltung sprengsatzes neben
nordkorea behauptet auch indien darüber
zu verfügen viele expertinnen und
experten vermuten dass diese länder
gegen der letzten zeit in den kreis der
sogenannten atommächte aufgestiegen
sind bisher keine einsatzfähigen waffen
dieses typs besitzen denn um eine
wasserstoffbombe zur explosion zu
bringen braucht es zwei schritte
ankommen wenn der sprengsatz zündete
zunächst die atombombe und diese
lösten die fusion aus wenn es neue
erkenntnisse zum atomprogramm in
nordkorea gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich
hier bei pixum wenn ihr kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt man hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
so wäre ein atomkrieg ein wirklich
erschreckendes szenario also nur drauf
klicken wenn ihr wirklich mehr darüber
erfahren wollte und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran